they are being
the time has come
Lakers fans please direct your attention
up to the southeast corner of the arena
where number eight and number 24 will
hang forever as we honor one of our
Lakers rates Kobe Bryant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I want to say you know it's thank you so
much for tonight but you know it's not
it's not about my jerseys that are
hanging up there for me you know it's
about the jerseys that were hanging up
there before and without them I couldn't
be here today they inspired me to play
the game on a high level magic camp
Shack pushing me every day bailing
Chamberlain Goodrich Wes worthy goes on
and on and secondly it's about this
class organization and Jerry Buss your
father believing in a skinny old kid
from Lower Merion High School in
Philadelphia and it's also about the
next generation it's about it's
currently a roster that we have here
it's about it's about embodying the
spirit that exists in those jerseys up
there and carrying this organization
forward so that the next 20 years are
better than the past 20 years and that's
what it's about and then it's also about
the fans fans
the media I don't think you guys
understand how present you guys were
with me you know you guys were there
with me at 5:30 in the morning when I
was running the track and I was midway
through my workout and I didn't know if
I could make it through and I thought
about the expectations you got hat you
guys have for me you have for our team
and it pushed me through it got me
through those eight hundreds and four
hundreds in 100 at 5:30 in the morning
so I thank you it's about family it's
about my wife Vanessa okay
you know you guys don't know this but
the last game my last game that we had
here against the Utah Jazz I was really
tired I got home and I was like you know
what I don't know if I can do this thing
I got one more game left but I don't
have any legs and she said I want to
show you something I got a gift for you
for your last game and she proceeded to
show me a row of retired jerseys from
Baylor for magic from Shaq from Kappa
all the personal messages science' me
including for Michael Jordan including
from the great Bill Russell included
from the great Larry Bird and when I saw
that I knew then that I had to turn it
up
so thank you baby for being an
inspiration to me and and lastly our
daughters Natalia Gianna and Bianca you
know I I hope that tonight is not you
know you guys know that you know if you
do the work you work hard enough dreams
come true you know that we all know that
but hopefully what you get from tonight
is outstanding that those times where
you get up early and you work hard those
times that you stay up late and you work
hard those times where you don't feel
like working you're too tired you don't
want to push yourself but you do it
anyway that is actually the dream that's
the dream it's not the destination it's
the journey and if you guys if you guys
can understand that then what you'll see
happen is that you won't accomplish your
dreams your dreams won't come true
something greater will and if you guys
can understand that then I'm doing my
job as a father thank you guys so much I
love you
[Applause]
[Music]
the eloquence of Kobe Bryant what a
night what a celebration very
family-oriented in his speech singling
out his wife and his three daughters
means so much to him this great Lakers
organization the bus family for sticking
with him believing in him a Laker for
life Kobe Bryant number eight number 24
forever hanging in the rafters at
Staples Center the only thing I mean
that was a no-brainer there the fact
that both yours could go up but I think
what matters the most is the message
that Kobe said to the fans but more
importantly the message that he sent to
the Kuran